quick tour update gang the state trashy
tour is a cook and we're adding shows
and we're coming to a city near you
bring the squad out and come see us yeah
baby plus we got new digs next week
we're going to be in Oklahoma City
Dallas Texas Houston Texas Austin Texas
Texas second show added there then in
April we're hitting New Haven
Connecticut Burlington Vermont new
second shows added in both those cities
what then we're going to Tampa Florida
second show added there you go Dania
Beach Florida Raleigh North Carolina
Louisville Cleveland get your tickies
now you snooze you lose see you out
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh baby it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that
after good to be classy yeah they're
just a big old piece of trash I'm your
host Dave trolley coming at you on a
glorious day we're out back here in the
new edition at hoodies baby oh the boys
climbed out of the basement Cody came
into a little medical malpractice money
uh-huh got the boys some new digs got
her a new set of implants and a one-way
trip to Hedonism Mike co-host is coming
at you from right next to me he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he is an international
businessman he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and I love him give it
up for KJ Kevin James Ryan everybody hey
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure your rate if
you subscribe on iTunes full video
available on YouTube as you know those
numbers are
and then obviously the greatest goddamn
website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage check it
out gang it's a full-blown party over
there love that money and having a nice
quick shout out to our producer
extraordinaire the magic man makes us
all look good works the ones works the
twos the threes and the fours now
crosses the t's dots the eyes and you
can get a little peek at him on the Toby
cam give it up for T-Bone mcgruffins
it's Toby McMullen everybody look at him
hey what's up dude hey here he is the
Edition is fire dude and what a perfect
couple to come Chris in it man we got
some prime time company dude yeah this
is great got a kid on the local news
right now
gang but the long hair ain't lying I
could not be more excited to have not
one but two incredibly special guests
here with us today she is a very
successful podcaster and producer and
she is the engine that drives the
machine he of course is one of the
funniest most hard-working highest
grossing stand-up comedians working
today oh yeah he is the host of bird
cast he is the co-host of two bears one
cave he is the Creator and star of
Something's burning he is currently on a
world tour has his own Comedy Festival
has a brand new Netflix special out
right now called Razzle Dazzle and as a
movie based on his life that he produced
and stars in guy's a worker hidden
theaters
May 26 and oh yeah he got Luke Skywalker
to play his dad we're talking Hollywood
power couple baby do us a favor give it
up for Burton Leanne
[Applause]
as you say it I'm like Jesus Christ dude
it's wild congratulations to both of you
yeah thank you I will say this I will
say this is the only moment of sincerity
I really genuinely could not have done
any of this without her I think
sometimes the reason I don't cheat is
because number one number one I'll throw
a bumpy start number one number one I'm
fast at sex and I don't want to show
that to anyone
but we'll talk later
about how fast I am do you remember the
time you laughed at me when I had an
orgasm yes she laughed out loud and went
that was fast that was even foreign
further
Leanne we have had bird on we know he's
certified garbage we do do on a little
bit of a background check on you we know
you're from rural Georgia yeah all right
um give us a little bit of that
backstory no how where how close was
your closest neighbor
oh God hang on this is the area they
this this is overall they families live
on like land right so neighbors are all
related right right that's right like
you have like a family has an area right
like a well I grew up on a road called
DOT road okay
they get worse hold on nobody has ever
said I grew up on a road
yeah DOT road was not paved when I was a
kid but it became paved as I grew up
okay we were related to everybody on the
whole mile and a half long road and the
end of the road was a community called
Bug scuffle
I told you I told you I brought a
[__] Baller in here
Birds bringing in [__] ringers dude
that ain't Fair what the [__] man funny
thing about Bud scuffle they were all
doctors
who so how long did the how long does
the land go back in your family well
um there's a church on the land that's
in my family and I think the sign on the
front says 1840. wow we got married in
that church we got married in that
church really it's one room one room
white clapboard one room Church yeah her
grandfather went to school in that
church my both my grandparents went to
school in that church he rode the
musicals in the hospital
a couple of heart transplants in that
place there was a swingers Lounge at
once tell that story
in 1800 swingers Lounge yeah maybe not
in that Community but and where did you
go where did you go to high school I
went to the local House High School
Bowden High School okay and what was the
mascot there Red Devil
oh yeah yeah
the Red Devil had a picture
there's a picture of Larry David our
first cut in the new studio
playing the hell burners next weekend
wow yes okay wow we're in it and how
many brothers and sisters do you have
none none you're your only child no okay
what'd your parents do for a living
growing up uh well when I was little My
dad's a mechanic still auto mechanic
okay and when I was really little my mom
worked in the local Factory that made
men's suits
but she later became a model when they
divorced we moved to a really really
beautiful woman whoa absolutely
beautiful
Atlanta for about nine years yeah yeah
she's from a smaller town than my dad
and I are from was there two guys there
uh pretty much yeah a smaller town than
Scott buffaloes yeah it's pretty small
pretty small
the mayor's a frog
man where did you go to school where'd
you go to college to college I went to
West Georgia College for two years and
then I transferred and went to Georgia
State University but I never graduated
okay never graduated no what happened I
moved to New York moved to New York and
just gave it up did you graduate come on
it took him seven years yeah I had to
you know my I had to take correspondence
classes through the Florida state prison
system
isn't that interesting this before the
internet that you two got it together I
mean to be successful is nuts I think
Scrappy is what we haven't in common or
[__] scrappies that's a trashy that's
a trashy girl thing we're Scrappy
of course okay I love it keeping off
some murderer
come on ice pick give me the answer
they sent me a box of books and a and a
shiv and a folder of tests and then they
were like there you go
that's it before the internet just
before the internet I mean the internet
was there but you work classes weren't
lined up oh yeah yeah and so yeah I left
Florida state but I hadn't graduated so
six hours shy try to take a
a uh uh something whatever the book I
didn't learn much uh whatever the group
of writers that wrote like uh Like To
Kill a Mockingbird and all those
American Writers okay uh and then uh
Harper Lee whatever that area of time
and then some other thing area of Viking
long ships correspondence courses liking
longship I had to do [__] I don't
know [__] long ships what my mom
wrote it um
25 years
old 25 years old and I called my mom I
said can you just please write this
paper for me and she was I go I gotta
graduate college and I'm [__] done
your thesis was on pontoon boats and
where did you two meet exactly at a
bowling alley we met in LA in a bowling
alley we met Nelly so you moved what did
you move to New York for originally I uh
moved to New York just to study acting
okay okay and I did that and then
started writing when I was here and then
I thought I got I got you know I'm from
rural Georgia so after being in the city
for a while I was like I need a little
bit of nature yeah it's too much City
for me so I was like well I'll try LA
and I moved out to LA and dropped acting
entirely I was like I don't think this
is for me okay they told her they told
her can I tell some of your stories guy
like um because he's a better
Storyteller no no no no they told her
they told her you need to gain weight or
lose weight either the fat chick or the
hot chick right and she was like I why
can't I just be me and at the same time
you edit this out if you don't want to
put this in she went to a party and she
met a woman who they said the same thing
to and she goes oh I'm going big really
just laying into it yes and that woman
was Melissa McCarthy
whoa yeah and it worked out yeah it
worked out I'm doing the same thing baby
hey me too
how fat do you guys want me
I said 600 I'll do it
you want me I can't shower by myself
hey Fame comes with a price baby and
that's two McDoubles
okay all right so you guys meet at a
bowling alley yeah and how long was the
courtship how long did you guys date uh
you don't remember go ahead it's the one
thing he doesn't want to tell year and a
half okay I also just heard the very
sweet story where you called her every
day at like 9 00 a.m every day right
yeah yeah what are you doing yeah and
the day after they met he called her
every day at nine a.m every day yeah
that is creeper status
yeah baby I'm out front of your house
what are you doing
you like it
although he didn't know it himself he'd
always be like yeah this is my friend
Leanne and it was playing a coin I was
like dude I'm your girlfriend you call
me yeah
stop calling me your boy
this is my buddy Leanne right
oh
it was the honeymoon remind me again
oh wow that's a story I believe you told
us a little bit about this when you were
on it was maybe not I can't I thought so
but I can't I don't know it was Little
Palm Island in the keys it a private
island that uh is my dad said I can get
a deal on it and so we said great so we
booked it and he goes normally it's
pretty expensive but you'll be fine and
so we booked it and we went and it was I
mean everyone was like millionaires
you guys aren't swinging at this point
oh at the time uh our wedding cost us
five thousand dollars because that's all
I had because I mean that's it so we
couldn't afford like anything sure the
charges for the church that was on your
land no no no no no no the food like the
the DJ do you remember where you got the
food no no no at our food for our
wedding yeah our my family made all the
food no way yes I paid for the stuff but
my my grandfather made we had like
barbecue some grandfather made pulled
pork my grandmother made coleslaw my
aunt made potato salad Brunswick stew my
yes we my grandmother made Brunswick
stew my cousin Brunswick oh wow probably
rabbit or something in there
there's something you shouldn't be
eating no there is you're right no
I always said you have to grade the
south on a curve but this is
but yeah what's in it uh Brunswick stew
is a stew that has
um Tomatoes yeah you're leaving strong
with tomatoes right corn okay and pretty
much whatever's left over from the pig
okay uh snout you know ear whatever's
left over and they kind of shred it all
grind it all is it good
choice of snout or tail whatever you
want to have I don't tell anybody that
you just say here's some Brunswick stew
hope you like it it's really funny so
you paid you paid for the wedding to get
to the store it did my Dad paid for the
DJ and I paid for everything else they
said they said they said at our wedding
you can either dance or drink you can't
do both that's right
we had to get special permission uh so
my dad was like Hey you know
like Footloose yeah yeah so my dad had
to go to the deacons of the church and
say hey he's Catholic so like these
Catholics are gonna drink like there's
nothing these are coming down hey for
the record my grandma wouldn't go
because they were Baptists we're
Baptists my grandmother was like why
would he have Baptist yeah that's old
school
right
different level of garbage yeah yeah
yeah yeah you guys might have my team
went up perfectly today I ain't doing
the Macarena with no Baptist all right
oh nobody in my family danced at all
nobody her dad had a panic attack
showing their ankles all right
oh my God I just thought of something I
forgot about this I got ready at my
cousin's house and drove myself to my
wedding in a pickup truck by myself
because I I was just like well I guess
it's time to go
and nobody's here so I'll just drive
myself in my makeup every time Liam was
pregnant at the time
and we we said as a joke not a secret
anymore
Georgia doesn't know well I know well
she might know now
the uh Leanne Leanne was uh they were
like hey does anyone have a shotgun we'd
love to take a picture with a shotgun
and everyone raised their hands they all
you hear shotguns so we took a shotgun
we took a picture with the the two of us
my dad and our preacher my dad's holding
a shotgun that's one of our wedding
pictures yeah they knew they knew oh
everybody knew okay yeah yeah well yeah
yeah yeah I mean I was 30. it was just
Georgia pick it up on that 32. yeah I
was not like yeah it's not my first
rodeo how was the old man when he found
that out did you guys destroy did you
guys hit it off right away or was there
a little bit of a me and her dad hit it
off right away but but my parents were
extremely my dad I'd already bought the
wedding ring the engagement ring with my
my dad my dad and I said before before
we knew I was before she was pregnant
okay we were already headed that way no
and I told my dad I said we were in at
the beach and and I said he goes so
what's going on with this chick I said I
want to marry her and he was like whoa
are you serious I said yeah she had
dumped me and it it destroyed me and I
was like and I I prayed to God if you
give me this woman back I won't [__] it
up and I will it'll be I'll be with her
forever this will be the one and then he
made a mixtape and put it on my
windshield of my car man and he said
wrote me a note that said please listen
to track number eight track number eight
is everything I feel I really [__] up
and track number eight describes exactly
what's going on for me I just lose your
Track eight why don't you just make
Track eight one track one right watch
ever [__] scan eight [__] tracks
Bert [__] Steve yeah tell a story he
wants you to stay there and stay there
and stay there
I'll do one more holy [__] creep
what was the breakup about oh [__]
no you got me too
he was coming too quick
oh back then I was laying it down
all right what's the next question
let me say this what an American success
story yeah I mean it's [__] Wild Man
uh talk about two people having each
other's backs and look what you look
what you've both accomplished there's a
moment there's a moment in our lives so
like I have to say this so when I when I
was doing the road and featuring and
then getting into headlining but it was
like 1300 a week
where were you at when you guys got
married where were you at in your career
I was I was a feature I was a fee
tracker featuring yeah I was featuring I
was not headlining yet
I hadn't had my first headlining date I
didn't get Head Start headlights like
middling I I actually when we first met
you're right I wasn't even Middleton
yeah doing a straight shooter
you barely had 15.
you were peppered In Crowd work when you
had to feature I want to be I like
that's where he was like no yeah she
lives in the truth no yeah which is
interesting and he wasn't making 500
bucks he was making 500 bucks a weekend
not 15. he didn't have ran the money he
didn't know how much money he makes now
yeah you're right and you control all
the finances
I don't know about control but because
he buys a lot of [__] without my
knowledge or permission
exactly do money trash and I'm here for
it it's bougie Bert I love it I feel
like they're both wrong
they're probably two different time
zones yeah one of those definitely isn't
set to Daylight Savings
neither of them are right wait how did I
not see that you walked in with two
watches on yeah so clearly after you've
got two watches you showed up late today
what the [__] let's get this guy a third
watch please Peter wait a minute dude
why did he wear two watches oh we were
in Vegas and we bought Tom and I uh
bought these before that remember you
had that with the I think the one on
your left hand no this is for my 50th
this one Tom and I just bought I love
that yeah this is a great one and uh and
I I'm I'm uh very OCD about losing stuff
and so I'm terrified I'll lose it I'll
put it somewhere and I'll forget it and
so I just was like I'll wear them until
I get home okay that's new buddy right
there that's all right
but uh but there was a moment there's a
couple moments you remember
when you're married that are pivotal
moments
and uh
Leanne were worked at a at the what did
you do I managed apartment building yeah
okay so we got us free rent
health insurance and health insurance a
little bit of pay okay enough to cover a
nanny for When I Was Gone on Monday or
on Wednesday Thursday Wednesday Sunday
or whatever yeah Wednesday Thursday he
he was literally like Daddy on duty
Monday Tuesday Wednesday every week and
then he hit the road so and we could
only afford my paycheck paid the nanny
for the two days a week she worked damn
so I couldn't really that's how we did
it I remember Leanne one time uh she had
Otto was a very frustrating child yes to
say the least yes and uh and Leanne had
broken our toilet in frustration a
little mommy moment and we were upstairs
and now I I will always say I'm the
luckiest guy in the world and I'm not
even just saying like uh look where I am
I'm so lucky I'm lucky on everything I'm
lucky on everything everything I'm
always [__] lucky and my whole life
I've been lucky I went to Scottish
college for seven years never picked up
a book and then Rolling Stone discovered
me sends me to New York I'm working the
door at the Boston Comedy Club Will
Smith discovers me I'm the luckiest
[__] guy you'll ever meet and we're
in our bed and million just breaks down
and she goes I feel like I ruined your
luck and I go huh she goes I'm bad luck
I'm ruined your luck and I remember
going don't say that out loud
you just jig stuff yeah yeah just jig
that I'm like maybe you are bad luck get
the [__] out of here you start pulling
out your eyelashes
and I said I said my luck is strong
enough for the both of us and I [__]
locked her into it and now we're here
it's great I [__] love it okay let's
talk about that mint mobile baby mint
mobile mint mobile mint mobile and it
caught him in the news recently Ryan
Reynolds making some serious moves but
here's the turkey what's that still
passing the savings on to you 15 bucks a
month over there at mint mobile gotta
believe it baby why not let's go yeah no
brick and mortar pass the savings right
onto you straight to the source baby I
know we're talking about it's fantastic
I've said it for years uh my wife has
been using mint mobile for years way
before the podcast even existed because
we got it on the ground floor baby you
better believe it all plans come with
unlimited talk text and high-speed data
on the nation's largest 5G Network you
can switch easily in minutes to get your
new Wireless plan for just 15 bucks a
Miz onth get the plan shipped straight
to your door for free there you go you
choose there you go to mintmobile.com
garbage one more time maybe that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
bill to 15 clams a month baby what's it
you're gonna get it ain't gonna get no
cheaper than that he's saving a lot of
scratch there that's mintmobile.com
garbage baby do it okay this is all
about butcher bucks baby oh give me the
meat you know it give them to me to my
door baby yeah you got a freezel for all
from right now don't you you better
believe it aren't you fatty you like
that you like that ground beef don't you
you like that grass finished
man you like that free-range turkey
turkey I know I do Gang butcher boxes
out really fantastic and when you get
premium cuts of meat you don't got to
pay premium prices nope when you go to
Butcher box yeah baby uh they've sent us
I don't know about a bajillion pounds of
me I got it coming on my gosh darn ears
I got ribs in there I'm gonna break them
out in a couple of days yeah get Uncle
Hank's special spices on there all right
this is a PG show delivered straight to
your door this humanely raised beef
chicken pork Seafood is an incredible
value like wild called Seafood yeah
[__] free shipping and always
exclusive member deals uh shake up your
meals with butcher box get free chicken
nuggets for a year
all right bring it back free chicken
nuggets for a year and 10 off your first
box when you sign up today I'm signing
up just to get those free chicky nuggies
no that's a 22 ounce bag of gluten-free
chicken nuggets and every order for a
year when you sign up uh putyourbox.com
ayg use code ayg claim this deal at
butcherbox.com
would you break on the toilet
the lid of the tank
what yeah I was really frustrated with
Isla and so I like put her in her room
close the door went in the bathroom
picked the lid off the tank and broke it
on the bowl and I was like I might be
having postpartum depression I may need
to go to the doctor yeah
[__] happens
you ever been hit with a toilet seat
she's like a pit bull
hey jeez Jesus
and also too we know you guys have a uh
have a big Life as a couple with the
with the dogs have a very big tight
circle of friends yeah it seems to be on
uh Instagram at least yeah yeah what's
that scene like when he rolls in we
heard about the uh the events at school
with the auctions and stuff like that
yeah he's just coming in a Clearing
House
uh you know what's really awesome about
where we decided to raise our kids
there's enough people there Bert at the
time when our kids were little wasn't
really what he is now wasn't really
famous so everybody just thought of him
as like another dad who is in Hollywood
somehow sure so we started this group of
friends and you know like one's a lawyer
one's in the world of VR and one's a
really big movie producer and we all
just they all just knew each other as
Just Dads yeah okay so he was just
regular you know and he still is when we
get together with them they're just like
he's just burnt and now do these guys
have two Rolexes just out of curiosity
no
one of them has one there you go
they're all they're all everyone's
really success successful very
successful but it's it you know a
different Arena like employment law not
entertainment law like employment law
like it's totally off what's the dynamic
if you guys all go out to dinner so
there's like four or five couple or
whatever three couples go out to dinner
who picks up to check do you guys take
turns do you have to fight for no I'll
split it I'll split it yeah yeah we all
split it okay right down the middle or
do you go like hey I had the nachos you
had no no just found out in the middle
okay I know yeah they're they're a good
group we all met because our kids all
went to uh the same school yeah same
school and all the all the girls were
doing uh Girl Scouts we all went for a
camping trip one time and be and and we
just all clicked and we called it
started calling ourselves the campers
it's the funnest part about being a dad
for me was the group you get involved
with at a certain age and show you guys
all your kids grow up together and you
hang out with them it's been it's the
one part that bums me out the most that
when dealing with Jordan going to
college yeah you start seeing them a
little less and less a little yeah a lot
less and less lately especially as
business because you're not home yeah
I'm never home I see them I mean we have
big events we do Chinese New Years with
them because one of the one of the mom
is Chinese we do uh during Hanukkah we
do latkes or pancakes and donut donuts
and so it's been it's dude I'm telling
you if you're ever thinking about having
a kid [__] yeah you have a kid you
watch them grow but the friends you make
right kids
the other guys you get to drink with a
lot of the kids are playing dude no
those have been the [__] funnest
those have been the [__] funnest well
luckily we found uh three other couples
who can party like he parties nice so
yeah there's at least one that'd be a
bad family that can can hang that would
be bad if you were partying and nobody
else you would have to be like we Bert
can't come anymore like everybody yeah
right yeah tuxedo shirt and a speedo
[Laughter]
going on oh it's still going on Isla's
still a girl
scouts
what are you dropping on Girl Scout
cookies between the two couple G's
Leon's a gangster she
she gave our daughters I mean this is a
compliment she gave our daughters the
childhood she never had so Leanne was
like I'm gonna be at Leanne literally
got got pregnant said I'm done with any
of my Hollywood career I'm gonna make
sure that I'm gonna be a hundred percent
of a mom we got offered a show on Travel
Channel one time I want to say it was
like twenty thousand dollars an episode
it was a lot and it was they would give
us coordinates of a place where a
treasure was and me and Leanne would
have to find get our way to get our way
there uh so it would be like off the
coast of Brazil
in 100 feet of water will be a treasure
chest and Leanne and I would have to
start and they'd track us there and I
said I was like done let's do it sounds
funny [__] Leanne's like no I go what
she goes no I'm a mom I'm not a [__]
TV show I'm a mom and I was like God
damn it would have been great money but
she gave the girl trying to do it
yourself for 10 G's
hey why don't we cast Leanne as a with a
young Latino chick huh all right my wife
won't do it but my daughter
[Laughter]
I want to do a little bit more
background on Leanne here please there's
some stuff we missed what was your first
job
uh I drove a tow truck for your first
job yeah I did wow well my dad's a
mechanic he had his own shop okay so I
drove his family business there's like
13. that was a [__] Repo Man at 13. I
ran parts and hey man you got to make
your payments
ran Parts okay yeah man that's some
Roughnecks
very trim and proper well put together
woman well you know I started driving
truck it's probably gonna say like you
waited tables at the local Diner or
something okay oh truck driver yeah I
drove a tow truck it was pretty fun
because I'd show up and these guys would
be like hey Leanne where's your daddy
and I go uh at the shop well who's
picking I mean like you in the truck and
I'm like I'm putting your truck on I've
been putting trucks
I was like seven I mean I've been doing
everything except driving the truck
since I was about seven so she's Darnell
help me get the truck off
what you talking about is I'm putting it
on and they'd be like what hey just give
a shotgun click
seven well I started riding in the
Wrecker with my dad when I was seven no
wrecker yeah up on up on Hopscotch
Mountain
it's a Blackjack Mountain
this is the best Blackjack Mountain that
sounds like a made-up Mountain okay
butterscotch okay here's a redneck thing
so my dad and I lived in a log cabin had
no heat it [__] sucked I had to cut
firewood all the time so we decided he
decided he was going to put a furnace in
it but we had to build a chimney for
this furnace so we went to Blackjack
Mountain in his Jeep with a trailer on
it to pick up rocks these big rocks on
the mountain to build this rock this
sounds like a story from the 1300s
we went to pick up rocks
big rocks for this chimney but Blackjack
is covered in rattlesnakes so
this is I'm watching this unravel and I
and I know how big the yarn gets so
here's what we did daddy said here's
what we're gonna do
you roll over the Rock
and I'll shoot the snake and then we'll
put the rock in the trailer sometimes
there'll be a snake under a rock
sometimes they're one okay so just roll
it over and use real quick and I'll
shoot it I don't remember how many
rattlesnakes we shot that day but it was
a lot so we had to do this over and over
like every weekend for several weekends
to get enough rocks to build a chimney
but yeah that was how we built energy
when I met when I how old were you by
the way
I was probably about 12 11 or 12. when I
when I met her dad and a rock and
rattlesnake we also had a snake we went
rock kitchen we had a rat snake that
lived in our bathroom and it was open he
was paying rent no he was eating the
rats in our house so he was like instead
of having a cat which we also had a cat
but we had a snake that lived in our
bathroom he coiled around the toilet and
we'd open the door at night it would go
shoot underneath the cabinet it was kind
of scary
yeah what do you mean it's a hillbilly
Roomba yeah
and her dad
I said uh yeah I'm Bert I'm dating I
think it was it
when he was living in the convenience
store yeah he did live in the back of a
convenience store in the freezer it was
the best behind the freezer you live in
the freezer it was the best friend who
did my dad your dad was living in a
convenience was he working there well he
was trying he was planning for his
retirement because you know being a
mechanic is pretty hard
so well hey you know nobody in EF Hutton
answering the phone please no right
retirement well he was doing two things
for his retirement he started uh
collecting big block engines okay to
sell later and then he bought a
convenience store and sold his house and
moved into the back of the convenience
store it was [__] awesome so you were
like I will tell you I was just I was
the
you were probably some Yuppie that came
in and was a steal on his daughter I was
a Yankee yes yes I was called a Yankee
and uh and he said to me when I met him
he said I said I'm Bert I I'm absolutely
adore your your daughter and he said
no boy you got one of the best frog
giggers out there Rob giggers
you just got yourself one of the best
frog figures out there oh you're a frog
you're the Frog Digger yeah yes was that
a frog catcher
oh yeah yeah so so we um you know we
didn't have we didn't have a lot of
money so when for fun we would camp on
the river and put a John boat in the
river and go up and down the river it's
a flat bottomed aluminum boat okay okay
um and gig for frogs well some people
have like the the like three-pronged
Fork that they like stab a frog with we
didn't have that you just kind of reach
in the bank and grab them but it's at
night okay so you have to like Spotlight
and you have to you have to this sounds
so redneck you have to be able to tell
them what are you kidding me back to the
gigging you have to take your Spotlight
and you have to be able to tell the
difference between frog eyes and Snake
Eyes so you don't grab a snake Jesus
dude so but so you spend the night just
grabbing frogs and you collect enough
frogs and then you you have frog legs
you eat frog legs man tough cookie
grew up frog gigging and also we did
something called set hooking where you
put like bamboo cane poles up and down
the side of the river to catch catfish
this sounds like another country no
no it's Georgia
I'm a Big Woods guy I grew up I like it
I love it it's so fun we'd go down there
to the river and uh drink moonshine
drink moonshine and and uh and all these
old men are the best storytellers in the
world I mean you hear stories and by the
way you want to talk about no political
correctness
I would be crying [__] her
grandfather was the best Storyteller and
he was he was an interesting guy he'd
grab you and walk you off into the woods
to tell you a story like just to get you
and then I mean that guy I really I I
I've [__] loved that he wore overalls
her wedding he was pretty he was pretty
real that's all right that's what I'm
talking about did he had like a shirt
and tie under them he did really yeah he
had a shirt and tie he wore his Sunday
overalls because you start with the
Sunday overalls and when you wear them
enough they turn into work overalls and
you buy a new pair Sunday gotcha because
the Sunday is like you know dark blue
sure so he wears Sunday overalls and a
coat and tie yeah I call her church I
just I just came up with a great
business model sidebar you should do
these live at first for birthday parties
what like if you did these as a live
event for for families who go I'll give
you 10 grand to come over and do a live
event and do it for our friends because
this is funny [__] to watch
this is funny [__] this is funny [__]
you are grossly overestimating the
income level of our listeners
[Laughter]
out there
we love you
um what else what else have you had just
as far as uh the cuisine so you've had
fraud frog legs yeah yeah I've eaten
snake what kind of snake
um I don't know not the one in the
bathroom I hope we kind of breezed over
that I feel for a live snake in the
bathroom yeah he lived there for like a
year or so and you when that was cool
you weren't scared you weren't yeah well
I've never been really scared of snakes
I used to collect snakes and lizards and
stuff in the woods all the time and keep
them for the day and then let them go so
no but if you went in to take a shower
or go to the bathroom you could see the
snake or you just knew it was like
somewhere you know how where the toilet
meets the floor you would curl around
that so he would be under your feet as
you were going the bathroom well no no
he was scared of me so as soon as I
opened the door he would go under the
vanity right he'd go under the vanity
sweating thinking about that here's the
thing there's so much wildlife in out
there there's it's you're in the world
yeah you would be petrified right I was
I was terrified
I was I was terrified every step of the
way she would sleep we'd go camping
she sleep on the ground outside open air
open early oh dude we never had a tent
we just left outside yeah and they had a
lake house but there was no house they
just have property by the lake where
they'd just sleep on the bank yeah on
the like on the outside and the first
time we did that she goes let's go sleep
outside and go with my mouth with my
mouth open I'm going out here catching
flies are you out of your [__] mind
like no I can't sleep outside
holy [__] I'll tell you there's my
Holiday Inn around here
my favorite Leanne Leon Chrysler she's a
really in chem story when we first
started dating and you can edit this out
if you're not comfortable the story uh
we get on the wave Runners out at the
lake this is my favorite story don't
hold on just I'll tell it probably who
had the wave Runners we had Rave Runners
now Leanna's [__] Fearless like like
a real jump off a cliff go as fast as
you can Fearless so she takes off the
Wave Runner and says follow me so I
follow her and by the time I catch up to
her she has gone into this little Nook
little opening the cove and it's it just
starts raining and she takes off her
bathing suit and is just swimming and
I'm like now by the way I'm [__]
terrified I'm terrified of alligators of
snakes no alligators where I live in
Georgia but and she's just I think she
goes come on in and I'm like
standing there crying with a boner
I want to get in the water but I'm
afraid of dinosaurs
but the whole time I'm looking for
something to bite me I was like I don't
want to die I don't want to die rednecks
are gonna walk down fall you ain't from
here yeah but yeah
it's like Leon is like that's growing up
out there you're Fearless you have like
they just it's a different cut kind of
person yeah no of course you have to be
Camp here's another fave let's talk
about bespoke oh I think you're talking
about box of awesome yeah I'm talking
about doing cool guys [__] yeah hanging
out with other cool dudes cool guy stuff
baby and a way to start doing that is go
over there that bespoke post get
yourself box awesome they send you cool
stuff here's the best part small
businesses from around the world helping
out the little guy start up brain
quality products I know they send them
to me every month I love them it's cool
guy [__] you never know you need it till
you get it you go look at this I'm
flexing on my Bozo brother my Bozo
neighbor whoever yeah
cocktail stuff you get outdoorsy stuff
stamps whatever you need baby buck knife
10 hammock whatever you want take the
quiz a box of awesome.com to get the box
that's perfect for you each box is
valued at 70 bucks but you pay only a
fraction of that price look at that uh
sign up is free and you can skip a month
or cancel at any time hit the pause
button if you need to here's the thing
don't recommend it though here's the
turkey get 20 off your first monthly box
when you sign up at box of awesome.com
enter the code garbage at checkout
that's box of awesome.com code garbage
for 20 off your force your first box box
of awesome.com code garbage do it okay
let's talk about Lucy
let's talk about Lucy getting into the
nicotine pouch game yeah all right
they're coming correct I was using the
other brand but now I'm a Lucy man like
a bow you're going to the gas station
and buying no-name brands with God knows
what in them you know what I mean like a
dirt ball uh-huh shout out to Lucy dude
changing a nicotine game once again
that's fantastic Lucy just takes the
edge off a little bit you're not
reaching for the smoke you're not
counting a minute so you get to go smoke
Lucy can help you baby there's a capsule
inside every pouch that you can break
and hydrate and get extra flavor baby
Savor the flavor I like that plus you
can save your child selfie a trip to the
gas station when you subscribe online so
you always got a box ready to go visit
lucy.co use the promo code garbage and
get 20 off your first order shipping is
always free that's lucy.co promo code
you know it garbage to receive 20 off
and always free shipping and here's the
fine print baby what do you got Lucy
products are only for adults of legal
age and every order is age verified this
nicotine this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical so you
know that so we like it back to the show
wait so just just so I'm clear so you
just had a lake house but there was no
house but you somehow you had wave
Runners that was a Boathouse okay gotcha
and then my dad's garage yeah yeah yeah
to store your boat yeah so if it rained
or something we would go in The
Boathouse and get out of the rain okay
no we just spent all our time on the
water and that's where the Jack boat was
no no no
that was that we actually had the lake
property when I was older like when I
was older the the John Boat stuff I
started doing actually like when I was
born you know like we did that all the
time and who got the wave Runners you
guys you guys
that kind of guy that could find a
broken wave runner for like 50 bucks
can't fix it okay now her dad her dad is
like I mean crazy with that [__] yeah he
is he's crazy with that pull an engine
apart rebuild the whole thing oh yeah no
that's yeah that's what he always did
man that's a real man right there throw
it on a record and then imagine she
marries me yeah I don't even know how to
change it it was an adjustment it was an
adjustment I had a moment of adjustment
where I'd have to go are you [__]
serious you're crying about that
it took me a minute to to find some like
understanding of like how he processed
the world she's very different than that
he's got two Rolexes on that have two
different times my dad does not have
that at all so it just took me a minute
sure I remember I remember on our
wedding day my dad my dad was doing very
well financially at the time and it was
probably the height of my dad making
money in his career
and he had a hundred and twenty thousand
dollar Mercedes and he pulled it up to
her Pop's house his her grandfather's
house where the the house
they built it by hand he built that
house and her grandfather had never
really seen a car like this and he just
it was almost like he stole the
catalytic converter
yeah
can I sit in this
he was like your dad's like no slams
before and my dad my dad my dad grew up
uh grew up did not grow up for money
right like so my dad is more will always
be a poor dude in his head yeah so he is
embarrassed that he has this car but his
grandfather was just like
like I mean open the trunk up like he
was like we're looking at this car yeah
we're inspecting it you push this and it
no key no key I mean it was like it was
funny [__] that's awesome that's awesome
can you do anything with cars at all if
you guys can drive one if you guys if
you guys I couldn't even buy one I'd be
serious I don't know I mean I've I've I
have a car broker I don't I don't go on
a lot yeah look at cars not now but like
maybe let's say 15 years ago or so if
you guys were like running to the
grocery store the car breaks down for
whatever reason
it's her you're sitting in the car oh
it's definitely well you get out and
will you troubleshoot will you like pop
the hood and like look at the spark plug
or the connection or anything no but I
usually know what's wrong like I'll go
oh this it's this whatever or she'll get
on the phone with her dad and go uh and
be and I'll just sit in the car yeah has
there ever been an instance where the
where you had a flat tire and Leanne
changed the tire and you were in the car
no no no would you do that
yeah I'd have her walk me through it
I'm not definitely I mean I don't mind
changing guitars I don't know what to do
foreign
if we gave both of you pickup trucks for
to race who do you think would win oh
it's her yeah I'm not I don't like well
I did drag race for money in high school
money beer money I respect that what
kind of car are we talking well my dad
bought me uh because my dad is very
smart and remember he's a mechanic sure
huh he bought me a 1979 Porsche whoa 924
which is not you know it was only four
cylinder not a super fast I don't know
what it means I'm a three-man myself
cylinders
I like cubes right dude who are you yeah
so this is crazy I know right it's like
a hillbilly Wonder Woman
love you Leanne you're all right it was
a colorful life it has been a colorful
life but my dad bought me that car
because nobody in the whole County had a
Porsche and it was red so he knew
everybody everybody knew where I was and
what I was doing all the time he's super
smart it's like a it's a low Jack it was
all before yeah yeah did he know you
were racing no well no he did he found
out and that he caught me once and then
he sold my car and gave me a Volkswagen
what does that what does that look like
as far as the racing you're in school
people people drive hey you want to race
well yeah you know where at what time we
met are you ready You're gonna laugh at
this on a hog liver Road
[Laughter]
only
the expert drivers race on hog River
Road the novices are down there on
rabbit rabbit Paul Lane uh you listen I
love I love where I grew up of course
it's so rich in in personality you know
and flavor and there's so many people I
knew that are and and still know that
are just so colorful in the best way I I
have a I have a theory on this of like
when you don't have much and there's not
a lot of money or anything you have only
the interpersonal relationships to rely
on yes you're not like Hey we're out on
this nice boat or in this cool house
you're like you you mean you're laying
in the grass sleeping you have to be
have personality you know what I mean I
think so I think it's less so now with
social media but growing up sure you
know 70s and 80s yeah it's all about who
you hung out with and there's some
colorful people so we're pulling up to
the line there's somebody standing there
with like a handkerchief or whatever
[Laughter]
zero
uh no gentlemen start your engines pick
me Tuscadero over there
you got her leather jacket on over your
shoulders I I look at Leanne I go I'll
be here when you get back
don't forget about me don't forget about
me she's smoking whatever fat boy drop
the flag
I live my life a quarter mile at a time
but the rules are there ain't no rules
about to win me a Toyota
she slaps you on the ass
there's not much to do there you know so
you gotta come up with something I said
I have it in my in Razzle Dazzle I said
she said one time to me and it [__]
blew my way [__] ain't nothing to do in
my hometown but [__] fighting race I was
like who did I marry Ricky Bobby
it's kind of true and drink yeah what
kind of cars would you be up against you
obviously had the hot ride in town right
well uh well sort of I mean a lot of
boys uh would were driving hot rods like
like one of my friends Dane Smith had a
Nova like an older Nova that he had
rebuilt I had another Chevy I knew a
friend yes another friend that had like
a Camaro Super Sport but it's an older
one like a 60 model 65 model okay so
those were hot rod muscle cars so you're
racing dudes yeah and my little I did
not I didn't say I won I just said I
erased a lot I tried I tried I want it
in the game you know it was fun well
there's nothing else to [__] do and I
was never very girly that way you know
to like I mean I was a cheerleader a
girly like that but but I I definitely
really got along with my dad my parents
divorced when I was seven and my dad had
two roommates in this Log Cabin okay so
I was with guys a lot doing guy stuff
yeah you know so and I drove a wrecker
you know drove drove a tow truck so I
was always in his shop would you go in
and see your mom on a regular basis live
with my mom for a time okay
um but I spent when I was living with my
mom I spent uh the whole summer with my
dad so three months from Memorial Day
Labor Day with me
um so it was Memorial Day my movie The
Machine comes out yes
which looks [__] awesome by the way I
remember you telling us about like you
know when you when you were saying about
it and I mean obviously I I knew how big
you were but in my head
the scope of that thing when I saw the
trailer I was like what the [__] it's so
good we do that [__] is so good I think
people I think I think Rogan said the
same thing he was like he was like it's
like a real movie yeah
and uh the number one thing that when
they did the testing they'd get done and
they go all right what's the number
what's what what what did you not expect
from this movie and everyone's
everyone's first thing was uh Bert can
actually act there you go it was I
because I didn't think I could here's
the thing about Leanne she's brutally
honest yeah I mean to a flaw to a
hardcore flaw it's not a flaw it is at
times at times at times when we left the
Greek and do you remember go I don't
know why I do it okay that was a flaw
okay so uh she will tell you exactly
what she's thinking and and it can be
abrasive when she first met me and she
saw me do stand up her first words were
go ahead and say it you're a lot funnier
than that you're smarter than your
comedy and I was like well it works like
yeah
so you need to like I had to put in
skanks for the memories to find out if
she had a good sense of humor or not ah
great album so we put in scans for the
memories and she was crying laughing and
I go okay she's right she's got a good
sense of humor I'm a horrible comic I
didn't say you were horrible I just said
you were smarter than what you were
talking about but when I did the machine
when I came and she came over to Serbia
and watched the first few days of
filming she was like you're you're
killing it and I was like wait I can act
and she's like yeah you can act and I
was like and that's when I was like
that's the beauty of having someone
tells you the truth is you know they
don't [__] around right yeah yeah it
looks [__] a tone of everything looks
[__] fantastic that's a major Motion
Picture we're talking about here yeah I
mean dude it was crazy the trailer looks
[__] awesome and just everything you
put into it and I never would have
thought like just the way you did it how
like it's you you're telling the story
and the the kid that you got
he's a great cast that's perfect casting
and I have to say Bert does almost all
his own stunts and all the fights
wait what yeah yeah I fell down I had to
go down a mountain I remember that and I
blew out my tricep and it tore off that
was before we knew you I think yeah yeah
wait really I didn't know that yeah yeah
I did all of them fight yeah and then
and then did you have to go to a Serbian
Hospital
[Laughter]
you're talking about being in some Lake
in Georgia if I ended up in a Serbian ER
I would freak the [__] out this I had me
to Mount Sinai ASAP serbians were
extremely protective of talking [__]
about Serbian Serbia sure like the the I
love them Toby cut that yeah you guys
are great I'm coming this summer Your
Health Care system is awesome I did not
I obviously opted not to get surgery
there
you're always an insurance issue that
wasn't my primary your arms hanging off
some guy with a bottle of vodka and a
butter knife look I can fix for you
you want sip of Porsche before we start
I burned my foot up I burned my leg on
an ice burn I put an ice pack on my calf
and it burned it and uh and the doctor
on set put Icy Hot on top of it and then
it bubbled up and I was like I'm not
going to the hospital to get surgery I
think you need a little butter
obviously we're joking shout out to
Serbia
you're huge and sir I don't know what
side I don't know what side they're
leading these days
we play right down the middle here
Serbia might be working for him in a
couple of weeks
I mean dude it's nuts I'm excited for it
I hope everyone enjoys it and and yeah
I'll be promoting the living [__] I'll
see if I can get Mark Hamill on here to
do all you garbage yeah how great would
that be okay you want to watch me cry
for about an hour are you kidding you're
gonna show it a lightsaber an amazing
interview he is an open book he he
literally is one of the funnest dudes to
be around because you'll be like uh just
random like uh I said something about
C-3PO and he just would tell you
everything you wanted to know about the
guy that played C-3PO and and and and
when the one time we were on set it's
like just everything he's the best dude
I was at the perfect age when that
dropped
my whole life just dialed in Mandalorian
now all the everything I love it man
yeah dude it's crazy you got Luke
Skywalker to play your dad he's so good
as his dad too he's really really oh
dude in the trailer these people come to
hear your made-up stories yeah or
whatever my dad that's my dad so I wanna
did you guys didn't film it at your
guy's house did you no it's like it
looked like it that wasn't Serbia it was
yeah oh so that's the house yeah oh
interesting it's uh the uh the first
night did it looked like such an LA
house dude what they Scout they did a
great job you filmed the whole thing
there the whole thing in Serbia
what yeah I know Jesus the first night
shout out to Hollywood we go to dinner
and the the woman played who plays the
villain in the movie The Blonde hit a
lady yeah she's great she's great she's
great she sits me down she goes hey
please don't bring up uh Star Wars
tonight to dinner I said why not she
goes I don't know I've never seen it and
I said oh okay she goes I know that's
like a big thing for Mark or something
but I don't know yeah and I don't want
to talk about it and so I go okay sure
so Mark sits down right Mr Eva and I go
uh Mark even is a huge Star Wars
and she like freezes and he goes yeah I
go Eva what did you like so much about
Star Wars like what's your favorite part
he goes oh I just died the whole uh good
guy versus bad guy thing I love it and
Marco's really and I said okay Eva who's
your favorite character in Star Wars and
you can't say Mark and she's like
um
Chewbacca and I go really can you do an
impression of Chewbacca she does a great
impression of Chewbacca Marcus he goes
oh oh yeah there's some Hello
Yakov Smirnoff plays Chewbacca she had
never heard of Deez Nuts you're just
that's a great bit so we I taught her
Deez Nuts and she does these nuts to
Mark Hamill who doesn't know what Deez
Nuts are dude I could just imagine this
group of eclectic actors sitting around
you're doing these nuts
we had a [__] blast we had a [__]
blast shooting that movie and I I hope
it does well and I'm gonna sign on to do
machine two three and four and I'm done
yeah that's it that's my career I'll do
[__] information I'm gonna be imagine
the Sylvester Stallone only did Rock
be pretty good
I've seen you and Cliffhanger three
holy [__] yeah I'm excited that's
awesome and you got we were talking
before you guys got in Shane Torres
I saw the story last night you were
working away the notes the whole night
it was so funny to be like I don't know
what's going on she's over there like
toiling away Leanna so well that's what
I do for him for his specials yeah so
when he uh talked to Shane about
producing a special for Shane he came to
me and said I'll do it only if you do
for him what you do for me and I love
that I love it it's great it's so fun so
that's what we did it's the Nuance of a
comic all the little eccentricities that
we have she has worked with me through
all of them on all my specials and so we
talked with Sheamus talking about doing
a special and asking me if I directed
here's how it started he said I have I
have X amount of dollars will you direct
my special and I said yeah I said well
why don't we Leanne said why don't we
just match whatever he has to put in and
then so that we can make sure it's
really good sure and so we said great so
we got a phone call we talk about the
money and I wasn't on the car Leanne was
and then Leanne just called and she goes
let's just pay for it and give it to him
because I don't want it it was
complicated like a bunch of people were
gonna chip in money and then ownership
got weird and Leanne goes no we'll just
pay for it and just give it to him and
then and just give him a great special
he's done so much for me he's the best
he's I mean shout out to him yeah he's
toured with me before all my specials
he's helped me all my specials like and
Shane's good it's like the new one type
of comic to be like I'd be like what's
that what's this bit missing and he goes
I don't know maybe a like a joke and
he's a straight shooter he's very
different than you yeah he's slow he's
very like new like he's just like very
and you're like a bigger thing yeah and
so he's dialed it he's so laid back
Leanne could pinpoint where the more
money spent well pays off
so she was first thing she's like you're
not directing this she was like you're
gonna fire the director immediately yeah
I respect that holy [__] and then hired
my director who does all my specials
hired my DP who does all my specials
that's right and then hired my editor
and then hired him that's all the time
that's right the editor they're dead
it's all my specials she goes why don't
you just come work for us and so she
hired all she's a mover and Shaker man
and then uh you got fired thank God by
his own wife I'm tired I showed up drunk
last night yes thank you yeah so see I
was right to fire him yeah talk on the
job I wouldn't I could have done this I
wouldn't know that's the shot you're
gonna use okay all right it's uh but it
it looks [__] amazing the venue
looked awesome it looks beautiful it's
[__] awesome in there and he murdered
the first show and we were like we got
it
and then Leanne went up pulled him aside
and said we have it uh Leanna Stacy said
what did you say to him oh we said you
we got it like if you if we we just
played start to finish we don't need to
edit it we got it so now go in and say
the things you didn't want on the
special expand it really really expand
on this joke and really give me more in
this place and just have so much [__]
fun and know that we have it so this
one's just for you just really have a
good time man so he did good it was so
made the second show was amazing I love
that amazing and he told several jokes
he didn't tell in the first show so I
was like this is the one that's great
hero dude
I bet there's people listening to this
going oh I I totally get why Bert got
her pregnant sure it was in traffic it
was entrapment entrapment yeah this is
the I bet people are like I bet first
actually not
I do not I do not I do not write
anybody's material I would never do that
that's not what you do what you do is
you say like hey you realize you say the
word like [__] four times in one
sentence Did you say it one time and put
a word when she edits my specials
meaning like we going together but I
can't it makes me really uncomfortable
sucks watching it and I and I don't have
the uh the wherewithal to look at it
from 2000 feet up and say and she'll
just go like this last special I opened
with a joke oh my opening joke that's
edited out was uh I want oh I was going
for a jog the other day and I saw a
homeless woman scratching off a lottery
ticket and I thought to myself what a
[__] waste of time and then I
wondered if she saw me jogging and
thought what a [__] waste of time and
Leanne goes that joke's good do you mean
to slow everything down and kind of lose
everyone's attention and I went huh she
goes I mean it's just why do we have
this here it's too slow it's too slow
and I went I wasn't my intention she
goes take it out was it your intention
to bore everybody
30 seconds in your space I like it did
you want that to stink
and so I took it out and then the
special starts so much better now but
that's what you can't see she's good at
that and so and she's I mean I'm
brutally honest I guess and I know what
I like and I know when I stop paying
attention so if you stop paying
attention something's wrong right of
course you should never stop paying
attention I'm just running through my
set in my head at the moment
you've convinced me that I am a horrible
look at me
but you can't say it multiple times in
one sentence then you're lazy and I'm
stealing that fat guy right now
imagine with this brutal honesty is like
in bed
how is that at the house
one time Leanne said uh we should talk
let's let's sit and tell the things that
we like and don't like sexually and I
went okay and I said
you'll remember in a second you go I
don't like licking so much and I went
all right I lick all the time she goes I
know and I said what she goes that's why
we're playing this game
and I went and do you remember what I
said I said what what do I like and I
said just my dick just touch my dick
anything with my dick and I'm good and
she was like I know but something else I
go just my dick she was like no like
what's something else you like I go just
touching my dick anything with my dick
she went I don't think you understand
the game
I like when he touched my wiener
that's awesome you're right I remember
now I didn't mean that I meant like
around the house like you know uh
wrangling him in laundry throwing this
around that around as a mess
what's the pain on the floor situation
over there the what being on the floor
does he miss a little bit no he doesn't
miss but his shits are aggressive and
the toilet is a disaster that's one
thing I'm not super happy about he
doesn't really mess with the p much he
also sits to pee a lot so hard to miss
when you say she is an open book huh is
that bad I'm sorry no no no no no no I'm
sorry I didn't mean to no no
expose you in that way but no no say yes
and my shits are explosive yeah she said
to me
she lifted up the toilet seat and it was
the underneath the toilet seat was
splattered with [__] and stalactite it
just because it it goes down then pops
back up I've had Taco Bell before and
then she said to me
if this has happened in the seat you
know this is happening to your legs and
I went what whoa and she goes there's
[__] all over your legs and ass too you
need to be like cleaning and I went it
was a game changer and I was like I
never even thought of that
would you guys excuse me for a minute
Toby get the fire I'm a bad comedian and
a bad [__]
and I don't flush what I'll flush what
it's awful it's awful uh listen
two things one before we got married I
said to myself you know who this guy is
he's a slob he's disgusting in a lot of
ways
you gotta go in it accepting that
there's no changing who he is
this is who he is right
and so sometimes I regret that talk to
myself because sometimes I go
surely I can change the toilet part I
mean surely we can change the telepod
but one time earlier in our relationship
he never flushes he shits and then he
walks away that's crazy it makes me
insane right because it's like human
nature to [__] flush so I said why
can't you flush just turn around and
flush and he goes you understand when
I'm on the toilet I'm thinking about
something else so by the time I'm done
I'm already on to the next thing so I
don't have time to flush and I'm like go
get it
that doesn't even make sense yeah
man I've once I've [__] I'm on to the
next thing it's my problem
I forget sometimes I'm going from there
to the shower I'll forget
but that's about it no every day no all
time I have a hard time even if it's
like real rough oh when is it not real
rough it's always real we'll just leave
diarrhea in the toilet 100 yes that's
insane I'll [__] in this toilet before I
leave and you'll see it no you will not
I got a little something for you boys
there oh a housewarming present from the
big guy but I think what it worked to my
advantage that I spent so much time with
men of this bachelor dad so it's a
little less jarring uh-huh yeah how do
you feel about his his booger picking
and eating it's disgusting it's
disgusting and he asks me to kiss that
mouth yeah that's crazy what dude you
came on the show the first time it was
the first time we had met you you came
in we were like oh yeah I pick and eat
my boogers all the time he then goes out
to dinner after you left our studio and
picked a booger you're at dinner and
sent us a picture of the booger and
you're like I'm gonna eat this
that is the most classy joint you were
at too that is the most aggressive thing
anybody has ever sent me on a [__]
phone and I've had a lot of wild [__]
I've had a lot of people support me on
this by the way I got into the comments
a lot of people I think first totally
saying
is there uh is there his and her sinks
you guys have two sinks
yeah it definitely isn't her sinks great
sure okay wild and how did you control
the uh the showering in the pool
what do you mean how do I control what
did you like what did you
how did you deal with that well I I mean
I don't that's just it's just I I don't
I'm not a big shower guy like she put an
outdoor shower in our in our new house
I'll I'll use that more than I will like
our indoor shower and it just gives me
anxiety just to idea that I have to stop
down and take a [__] shower I'd
rather just jump in the pool I have
shampoo out by the pool you shampoo wait
a minute hold on no wait I think wait
what I thought you just rinsed off no no
I rinse off he's getting I keep shampoo
out by the pool I'll shampoo in the pool
yeah my dad's the one that taught me it
when we go you can't mix chlorine with
that yeah you can that's how you make
mustard gas
that's not right dude I thought you were
just dipping in I go I'll give you that
no the chlorine will kill whatever boobs
I'll do uh I'll keep uh uh uh what's the
[__] what's the manscapes I keep the
manscaped shout out to Nancy stuff sorry
body wash and shampoo smells good it
smells awesome right yeah yeah do I keep
it by the pool and I'll shower I'll wash
my hair and then dunk under wash my pits
dunk under and I'm good
and there's just soap in the pool yeah
it's a pretty big pool goddamn oil spill
in there now that's there's a slick on
top of that that's like Chum dude no no
it's it's it's great it's [__]
awesome
I would I would I wish they had like big
man baths like that where you could just
jump in and just
like a Russian bath house yeah I saw on
a Polar Plunge now it's on a pump punch
and then I'll wash on the back shower I
can for whatever reason an outdoor
shower is a lot more that's the best
it's the best I love it I love it for
the most part my my bathing is uh sauna
Polar Plunge outdoor shower
are we moving away from the swimming
pool showers no and and the reason is is
like I get backed up I get busy and I
just don't have time to shower so I just
jump in the pool I lately oh 100 jump in
the pool and do after and do pool bass
because I've been like I'll work out and
then I'll have a podcast starting in
like 15 minutes and I don't have time to
take a shower I just gotta do a pool
bath throw on jeans here's a question
tell you why that doesn't bother me why
because we grew up having what we call
Doc baths where you jump in the lake
lather well you thought jump back in the
lake I've heard all I need to hear to
render a verdict on this one so I think
I understand the pool back I think the
Lake's better than the pool though no no
I don't know well this likes it seems
more natural lake a lake a doc bath as
soon as I fought it's all about doc math
I was like [__] I'm in I'm in are you
kidding me this is the one take a duck
bath and then get on a [__] plane fly
back to LA still have the lake on you oh
come on that's it
I'm the best
I've never heard anybody said still got
the lake on here
algae feel on me this smells like
minnows Jesus Christ it's a pretty big
lake all right we gotta wrap it up
though Gang Ladies and Gentlemen We
[__] love you thank you so much
Leanne Chrysler the Chrysler's here
certify trash
level but what a [__] story man what
a success story crazy
[Applause]
no
Lanes in Hot River Lane is Two Towns
over
holy [__] congratulations on the Razzle
Dazzle congratulations well yeah
congratulations on everything the movie
comes out May 26th Memorial Day Weekend
the machine comes out you can go to the
machine dot movie if you want to pre-buy
your tickets we're doing a pre-buy
option so that we can sell it out before
it even gets into the theater that's the
way we sell tickets for comedy we
thought we'd do that and we're going to
do a live in studio uh event that'll be
streaming directly into into this
theaters on the screens whoa my special
Razzle Dazzle streaming right now on
Netflix I hope you enjoy it I hope you
like it and uh fully loaded to come in
the summer
and
fullyloadedfestival.comfestival.com the
cruise uh we have the cruise I think
that's sold out yeah so yeah
sell it out I never thought I'd be here
I never thought you guys are killing it
man you deserve every single thing you
have we love you both thank you so much
for being our first guest here in the
new edition congratulations on your
studio is amazing thank you so much we
appreciate it Kippy what do you got for
him guys we're all over the road tickets
are selling out so get those tickets now
patreon.com the whole nine yards we
[__] love you thank you gang we can't
thank you enough for getting here we
love you and we'll see you next week